coming up next week at the Strasbourg
plenary migration the Digital Agenda
maternity leave and tobacco welcome to
the agenda at a time when countries like
the UK according to stricter immigration
control will they get behind a new
migration policy that would impose
countrywide refugee quotas the crisis in
the Mediterranean is reaching breaking
point EU leaders have already promised a
bolster presence of sea and to fight
traffickers the commission president mr.
Younker could invoke temporary emergency
powers allowing the Commission to force
member states to take in refugees what
will Parliament have to say find out on
Wednesday over to the votes on maternity
leave will mothers get more time at home
with any babies the commissioner said
that if member states and the Parliament
can't shake hands they'll withdraw the
legislation the issue is that both sides
are digging in their heels on the
increase of leave mothers would get
currently it stands at 14 weeks the
Commission had proposed 18 weeks but
Parliament increased this to 20 weeks a
fully paid time off work and member
states many of whom have different time
scales for maternity leave fault so
we'll institution fighting see it dead
in the water we'll see on Wednesday
could the sixth of may be seen as
Europe's digital awakening well that was
a day when the EU Commission have
finally dropped its draft proposal on
the EU single digital agenda before
Europe can be taken to infinity and
beyond delivering citizens better prices
services and access parliament needs to
put together a report of its own meph
will debate and vote on the steps ahead
should the EU really be doing deals with
tobacco companies to stop contraband and
counterfeit cigarettes getting on the
market last year a revised tobacco
products directive came into force
putting controls on the marketing and
distribution of tobacco-related products
a further deal making the EU over 2
billion euros was made between the
Commission and for the biggest tobacco
manufacturers to limit black-market
cigarettes but now that very deal may be
killed off look out for the debate at
the plenary and that's all we have for
this agenda take care and enjoy the
weeks